[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
das früher 2020 wird lange in erinnerung
bleiben sechs wochen lang wurde
deutschland praktisch von einem
notstands regime geführt dass in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik ohne
beispiel ist unser antrag will das in
zukunft verhindern
reagiert wurde deutschland de facto von
der bundeskanzlerin und den
ministerpräsidenten auf dem
verordnungswege ohne echte
parlamentarische kontrolle
das grundgesetz kennt einen solchen
notstand nur für den verteidigungsfall
nicht für den fall einer epidemie für
den krone ausnahmezustand mit einer so
weitreichenden außerkraftsetzung der
grundrechte gibt es in der verfassung
keine grundlage das grundgesetz erlaubt
zwar die einschränkung von grundrechten
zum schutz anderer güter zum beispiel
natürlich zum schutz der gesundheit das
aber nur nach strengen regeln der
verhältnismäßigkeit und in jedem
einzelfall unter dem eindruck der korona
krise hat die exekutive in die
grundrechte so drastisch und so pauschal
angegriffen dass diese
verhältnismäßigkeit massiv verletzt
worden ist jeder tag an dem dieser
zustand andauert untergräbt das
fundament unserer demokratie und unseres
rechtsstaates
die bundeskanzlerin hat die notwendige
debatte über den lock down und die
lockerung wie wir alle wissen als
eröffnungs diskussions orgie denunziert
das zeigt ihr tief gestörtes verhältnis
zu rechtsstaatlichen
die fdp fraktion hat sich bereits vor
ostern für eine zügige aufhebung der
beschränkung ausgesprochen die
bundesländer schwenkten in den letzten
tagen auf diesen kurs ein
dass sie merkels solchen regiment die
gefolgschaft aufgekündigt haben ist ein
befreiungsschlag
es ist richtig die hauptverantwortung
liegt bei den ländern aber der bundestag
kann sich nicht auf die rolle des
zuschauers zurückziehen es ist unsere
aufgabe der bundesregierung führe
gespräche mit den ländern einen klaren
auftrag zu erteilen
wir fordern mustervorschriften für die
parlamente für verhältnismäßige
entscheidungen statt der bis heute
waltenden politischen willkür der
exekutive die außerkraftsetzung der
grundrechte war ein gefährlicher
präzedenzfall der sich nie wiederholen
darf
die politischen ökonomischen sozialen
und kulturellen folgen betreffen die
gesamte deutsche nation dass die kirchen
in diesem jahr zu ostern leer bleiben
mussten
das ist keine fußnote das ist ein symbol
für die tiefe krise unserer christlichen
kultur in zeiten der völligen
moralischen beliebigkeit dass nur drei
wochen nach ostern das
das gericht die gottesdienste für die
muslime zu ramadan erlaubt hat beweist
unsere ostergottesdienste hätten auch
stattfinden können und müssen ihr verbot
über reine willkür es ist das ergebnis
der gleichgültigkeit und der
respektlosigkeit zu großer teile der
politik gegenüber unserer eigenen
christlichen kultur die gegenwärtigen
lockerungsmaßnahmen bedeuten nun aber
kein schutz für die grundrechte in der
zukunft denn die exekutive behält sich
vor bei einer undefinierten zweite welle
zum solchen regiment zurückzukehren
die grundrechte sind der schutzschirm
der bürger gegen den staat und stehen
deswegen nicht im belieben der regierung
was passiert wenn der schutzschirm reist
haben in den letzten wochen gesehen das
ende der versammlungsfreiheit das ende
der glaubensfreiheit und die
hunderttausendfache zerstörung
bürgerlichen existenzen
wir lassen die grundrechte uns nicht
nehmen nicht in der korona krise und
auch in keiner anderen krise nicht von
dieser regierung und auch von keiner
anderen ostern ist ausgefallen
weihnachten werden wir feiern
wer tricks von storch für die
fdp-fraktion da ist die stellvertretende
vorsitzende hat die beiden anträge die
hier von der afg vorliegen erläutert und
jetzt geht es weiter zunächst mit
philipp am tor aus der unionsfraktion
mitglied im innenausschuss und danach
kommt konstantin kohle der
innenpolitische sprecher der fdp und ich
vermute mal es wird ein bisschen
munterer werde präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ja wir haben es
mit den wohl intensivsten
freiheitsbeschränkungen in der
geschichte des grundgesetzes zu tun und
es ist richtig und es ist legitim dass
man die hinterfragt dass man sie
gegebenenfalls auch kritisiert und es
ist richtig dass wir das hier im
parlament tun
der par das parlament ist genau der
richtige ort dieser debatte
das parlament muss aber vor allem auch
der ort einer anständigen diskussion
über die verfassung und eines
vernünftigen umgang stones sein und den
haben sie völlig verfehlt frau kollegin
von storch liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen schon der antrag der afd
entlarvt sich doch dem titel nach
grundrechten trotz corona wieder geltung
verschaffen
das insinuiert doch quasi schon als
würden die grundrechte nicht gelten
sie reden hier von einer aussetzung der
grundrechte von einem solchen regiment
und ich sage ihnen von diesem wedding
von dieser logik ist es nicht mehr weit
zu den verschwörungstheorien die dieser
tage eine große geplante online
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und das
was hier vorgestellt haben
da muss man sagen da können in einigen
jahren parlaments historiker noch mal
nachforschen ob an ihrer universität
damals tatsächlich staatsrecht gegeben
wurde oder nicht anwesend waren sie
scheinbar nicht frau von storch und wir
müssen sagen ja man kann das gerne
kritisieren die freiheitsbeschränkungen
aber man kann beim besten willen nicht
behaupten die grundrechte seien außer
kraft denn die vergangenen wochen haben
doch gezeigt dass auch in den zeiten der
krise gerade nicht das recht es
vermeintlich stärkeren sondern die
stärke des rechts gilt es gab
rechtmäßige maßnahmen und es gab auch
unrechtmäßige maßnahmen es gab mut und
es gab auch übermut
aber die grundrechte sind ihrer
bedeutung als abwehrrechte des bürgers
gegen den staat gerecht geworden und ich
weiß nicht was ihr rechtsverständnis ist
von der ard aber unsere bundesregierung
und uns als parlament muss man nicht
extra aufwachen dann sich an die
grundrechte zu halten sondern die
grundrechts bindung gilt kraft von
artikel 1 absatz 3 für uns automatisch
da sollten sie sich lieber hinterfragen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und die
vergangenen wochen haben auch bestätigt
dass die grundrechte konsequent
staatlichen handelns grenzen ziehen
gerichte bis hin zum
bundesverfassungsgericht haben maßnahmen
bestätigt aber maßnahmen eben auch
aufgehoben
reisebeschränkungen ausgangs
beschränkungen demonstrationsverbote und
um das aufzuheben braucht es nicht die
afg und auch nicht ihren antrag der
beschränkt sich allein auf ein
rekapitulieren der rechtsprechung und
bringt keinen mehrwert liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen und ich will trotzdem sagen
ich kann die art der ja ein bisschen
verstehen warum sie hier diesen zirkus
aufführen
corona macht es ihnen ja auch wirklich
nicht leicht
sie verhalten sich da ja ein bisschen
wie das fähnchen im wind erst gab es die
verschwörungstheorien die regierung
ignoriert das virus die maßnahmen kommen
zu spät
dann waren ihnen die maßnahmen zu hart
jetzt gibt es neue verschwörungstheorien
manche von ihnen finden die klasse
manche nicht und das problem ist
offensichtlich auf einmal fühlen sie
sich vielleicht so ein bisschen die wir
jetzt haben sie auf einmal rechts neben
sich fake news truppen die sich auch aus
ihren instrumentenkasten bedient tut mir
ja leid ein bisschen für sie und
außerdem haben sie noch das problem
irgendwie als problemursache für corona
merken ist nicht schuld ich flüchtlinge
sind nicht schuld ist eine schwierige
lage und da muss man sagen dieses
problem ist für sie einfach eine nummer
zu groß liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
so und gerade weil das so ist sollten
wir im parlament die zeit auch nicht
nutzen uns mit ihrer propaganda zu
beschäftigen sondern lieber mit der
sinnvollen frage wie man jetzt als
gesetzgeber und auch als parlament
sinnvoll über grundrechte und die
verfassung diskutieren sollte denn ich
habe es gesagt wir haben es mit den
intensivsten freiheitsbeschränkungen in
der geschichte unseres landes zu tun und
wir müssen zur kenntnis nehmen dass
diese freiheitsbeschränkungen eben an
vielen stellen auch mit mich teilweise
überraschender gigantischer zustimmung
zustande gekommen sind
freiheit einschränkungen mit donnerndem
applaus und manche haben dabei eben dann
auch gesagt ja die gesundheit sei so
etwas wie das neue super grundrecht
manche staatsrechtslehrer haben deshalb
davor gewarnt dass wir uns von einem
freiheitlichen rechtsstaat bewegen
könnten zu einem hysterischen hygiene
statt
und natürlich kann man sagen diese
warnungen sind übertrieben und natürlich
hat mancher gesagt in den zeiten dieser
wirtschaftlichen krise über grundrechte
über verfassung zu reden das ist doch
ein bisschen abgehoben das ist
theoretisch ich sage aber die frage der
grundrechts bindung ist keine
theoretische frage es ist eine eminent
entscheidende
das praktische frage sie betrifft die
gewerbefreiheit die religionsfreiheit
die reisefreiheit und deswegen ist es
richtig dass wir denen widersprechen zu
sagen dass die diskussion nicht wert
jetzt ist die zeit des handelns jetzt
ist die zeit der stunde der exekutive
da kann ich nur sagen das mag richtig
sein aber richtig ist auch ja es ist die
zeit des handelns und politiker die aus
angst vor dem handel nicht handeln haben
ihren job verfehlt und ja es ist auch
richtig zu sagen es ist die stunde der
exekutive
aber es ist eben auch die stunde des
parlaments und vor allem zu jeder zeit
die stunde der verfassung und das ist
der geist den wir auch als
selbstbewusste parlamentarier senden
müssen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und deswegen ist die frage der
grundrechts bindung eben kein
schönwetter thema sondern wir müssen
wissen je länger diese
freiheitsbeschränkungen andauern desto
begründung bedürftiger werden
und deswegen ist es richtig dass wir uns
auf den weg zu lockerungen machen denn
das grundgesetz zwingt uns vor allem zu
einem permanenten abwägen
ich kann nur davor warnen das denken der
afg zu übernehmen schwarz oder weiß null
oder eins so funktioniert die verfassung
nicht es geht nicht um gesundheit oder
wirtschaft gesundheit oder
religionsfreiheit es geht immer um
gesundheit und wirtschaft gesundheit und
religionsfreiheit gesundheit und andere
grundrechte und genau darauf müssen wir
setzen diese abwägung müssen wir hier
einfordern
das müssen wir begleiten das erfordert
feinjustieren austarieren und das ist
meine damen und herren nichts für die
verfassungsrechtlichen grobmotoriker der
afd
ich kann nur sagen diese grundrechts
abwägung ist eine operation am offenen
herzen und sie haben auch in ihrer zeit
im deutschen bundestag ihr op besteck
für verfassungsrecht noch immer nicht
gefunden
wir lehnen tieren antrag ab sagte die
bankerin politiker in der unionsfraktion
und ja auch wenn man so will ein corona
an dem opfer denn eigentlich könnte er
möglicherweise jetzt schon
landesvorsitzender der cdu in
limburg vorpommern seien aber bleibt
muss noch ein wenig warten wenn er
gewählt werden will k s hat die kohle
innenpolitischer sprecher der fdp
fraktion telefonat mit einem herrn aus
niedersachsen der mit seiner familie in
stade eine reisebüro betreibt und für
die reisebüros ist dass momentan keine
leichte zeit die einnahmen brechen weg
es gibt keine perspektive für den sommer
und deswegen haben sich die betreiber
dieses reisebüros mit anderen zusammen
getan um eine demonstration zu
organisieren wir wollen eine richtig
große versammlung machen um auf ihre
sorgen und nöte aufmerksam zu machen und
da hat er sich an mich gewendet und hat
gefragt dürfen wir das überhaupt ist es
überhaupt gestattet in einer solchen
zeit corona der stadt ergreift starke
rate maßnahmen eine versammlung zu
machen ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht
aber mir bricht das das herz denn wir
brauchen auch in diesen zeiten
bürgerinnen und bürger die ihre
grundrechte nutzen die auf ihre sorgen
und nöte aufmerksam machen und auch die
grundgesetzlich geschützte
versammlungsfreiheit für sich nutzen und
deswegen ist es gut dass wir hier über
die versammlungsfreiheit miteinander
debattieren
ich wundere mich ein bisschen meine
damen und herren darüber dass es in der
debatte über die versammlungsfreiheit
über die korona maßnahmen so was gibt
wie autoritäre reflexe da wird sich
mitunter darüber aufgeregt dass
lockerungs diskussionen geführt werden
da werden diejenigen diffamiert die sich
für öffnung einsetzen aber ich dir eines
sagen es ist ganz wichtig dass wir die
debatte über öffnung und über
lockerungen hier im parlament führen es
gehört zu einer freiheitlichen
demokratie dazu dass wissenschaftler
sich auch in der öffentlichkeit
widersprechen können es gehört dazu dass
medien unterschiedliche thesen austesten
können dass man dort miteinander
diskutiert denn ich will ihn eines sagen
wenn diese diskussion nicht
moment nicht in der freien presse wenn
diese diskussionen nicht in der
wissenschaft stattfindet dann findet sie
in irgendwelchen obskuren telegramm
gruppen von c promis staat beklatscht
von den rechtspopulisten der afg und
deswegen müssen wir hier über
grundrechte und über die
versammlungsfreiheit diskutieren und das
nicht nehmen am rechten rand überlassen
gestern hat meine damen und herren hier
vor dem gebäude eine demonstration
stattgefunden weil der am ende ein
kamerateam der ard angegriffen worden
ist und ich will dazu zwei bemerkungen
machen erstens die versammlungsfreiheit
gilt immer nur friedlich die menschen
können sich versammeln
ohne wasser und friedlich aber wer unter
dem deckmantel der versammlungsfreiheit
dieses grundrecht missbraucht um die
journalisten anzugreifen der muss mit
einer harten gegenreaktion des staates
rechnen
deswegen gilt meine zweite bewerbung
gilt mein zweiter den polizistinnen und
polizisten die weiß bot keinen einfachen
job da gestern hatten dort die
pressefreiheit hoch zu halten und
gleichzeitig übrigens auch ein zeichen
an die friedlichen demonstranten und
friedlichen demonstranten zu senden
vielen dank an die mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeiter im öffentlichen dienst bei
der polizei dass sie gegen diese truppe
unsere grundrechte hochhalten die haben
es wirklich nicht leicht
ich glaube
dass wir angesichts der massiven
einschränkungen der grundrechte diese
momentan in der bundesrepublik gibt hier
darüber diskutieren müssen wie wir
strukturell livia institutionell unsere
grundrechte wieder mehr in den
vordergrund rücken können und dafür
machen wir als freidemokraten im
wesentlichen drei vorschläge erstens
sollte es immer um materielle kriterien
und nicht um formelle kriterien geben es
ist egal ob da 20 30 oder 50 menschen
demonstrieren wenn die hygiene und
abstandsregeln eingehalten werden dann
ist der versammlungsfreiheit der vorrang
einzuräumen und israel zeigt das
übrigens bord haben
2000 menschen in einer demokratie gegen
die regierung demonstriert unter
einhaltung der abstandsregel und das ist
möglich also in einer demokratie gibt es
auch im coroner zeiten
versammlungsfreiheit und deswegen muss
das ganze an materiellen kriterien
ausgerichtet meine damen und herren mal
darüber unterhalten wie wir die
diskussion über grundrechts beschränkung
weg von der exekutive hin zur
legislative bewegen es ist in ordnung
dass der staat in so kurzer zeit auch
pragmatisch als exekutive tätig wird
aber je länger diese maßnahmen dauern
umso mehr müssen die debatten darüber im
parlament geführt werden übrigens nicht
nur im deutschen bundestag sondern auch
in den landtagen artikel 80 4 des
grundgesetzes gibt dafür einen wichtigen
hinweis wenn die länder rechtsverordnung
machen können auf der grundlage des
bundesrechts dann kann das auch im wege
von gesetzen erfolg deswegen sollten wir
hier die länder auffordern den
gesetzesweg zu wählen und sich nicht
alleine auf rechtsverordnungen zu
beschränken
und zu guter letzt meine damen und
herren sollten wir uns auch dafür
einsetzen dass es eine freiheits
kommission gibt beim deutschen bundestag
in der nicht nur die virologische
sichtweise sondern auch die
psychologische die soziologische die
juristische sichtweise zur geltung kommt
so können wir was für die
versammlungsfreiheit in deutschland
erreichen mit ihrem antrag nicht kindern
prozent kohle innenpolitischer sprecher
der fdp fraktion und daher
demonstrationen gestern hier vor dem
reichstagsgebäude erwähnt hat und auch
das verhalten der polizei erwähnt hat
vielleicht auch egis carsten hilse der
hier an ist als kandidat für das amt des
bundestagsvizepräsidenten
hat vorgestern auf seiner facebook seite
einen offenen brief veröffentlicht an
alle polizisten und darin geschrieben
die sich das ich liebe polizistinnen
egal auf welcher ebene sie tätig sind
sich bei den demos gegen die content
beschränkungen wie er schreibt auf die
seite des volkes zu stellen und bedenken
gegen die rechtmäßigkeit der
dienstlichen anweisungen die so wörtlich
zu unnötigen und rechtswidrigen
grundrechts einschränkungen und führende
versagen bei ihren vorgesetzten die
anzumelden
also diese information vielleicht auch
noch am rande schreibt er auf seiner
seite lasst es nicht dazu kommen dass
sich der zorn der bürger auf die
politiker die die derzeitige situation
zu verantworten haben auf euch und lädt
ein offener brief ich gesagt von carsten
gelse der für das amt des
bundestagsvizepräsidenten ihr heute
kandidiert jetzt machte mir für die
spd-fraktion es auch noch die letzte
seite mit der schlussfolgerung abhanden
gekommen ist
ihnen fehlt schlicht die haltung sie
ziehen keine politischen konsequenzen
sie zeigen kann weg auf für eine
entscheidungsfindung die veranstaltungen
und religiöse feiern wieder begangen
werden können sie sind darüber hinaus
auch einfach spät dran
denn viele demokratische
protestversammlung und zusammenkünfte
zur religionsausübung werden mit
vernünftigen mit notwendigen
beschränkungen und auflagen schon längst
wieder durchgeführt während sie anträge
geschrieben haben haben wir uns mit den
menschen zusammen gesetzt und auch
vernünftigen lösungen gesucht wie
versammlung in diesem land möglich
werden so macht man politik für die
menschen die versammlungsfreiheit und
die religionsfreiheit werden hier
einfach zusammen gewürfelt
dabei verkennt die afg fraktion dass die
versammlungsfreiheit schon durchgesetzt
durch das versammlungsgesetz beschränkt
wird und die religionsfreiheit nur durch
güter von verfassungsrang überhaupt in
die schranken verwiesen werden kann
darüber hinaus ist jede maßnahme einer
verwaltungsstelle immer zugleich auch
eine einzelfallentscheidung
diese unterliegt der verwaltungsinternen
der gerichtlichen aber auch der
parlamentarischen kontrolle nicht
zuletzt über die rechtmässigkeit um das
ermessen
man spürt bei diesem antrag auf förmlich
dass sich die fdp-fraktion ärgert sie
ärgert sich darüber dass der antrag sich
überholt hat sie ärgert sich darüber
dass dieser rechtsstaat intakt ist weil
ein intakter rechtsstaat entzieht ihnen
ihre existenzberechtigung mit allen
behörden die wir zur verfügung
zu ihren forderungen im einzelnen darauf
hinzuwirken dass
bundesverfassungsgerichts entscheidungen
geltung zu verschaffen ist verkennt
schlicht dass dies bereits im gesetz
steht frage auf 31
bundesverfassungsgerichtsgesetz einfach
mal lesen lesen bildet schließlich
folglich würde eine missachtung eines
einen rechtsverstoß darstellen und ich
nehme an dass sie nicht hier pauschal
vorwürfe gegen regierungen und rathäuser
erheben wollen dass sie vorsätzlich sich
nicht an recht und gesetz hält
angemessene begehung von religiösen
veranstaltungen und insbesondere das
letzte geleit für verstorbene werden von
den kommunen und dem geistlichen
beistand unter den gegebenen umständen
sehr sensibel gehandhabt und
beschränkungen hier auch wie ich finde
sehr gut erklärt das heißt auch hier
brauchen die menschen kein afg antrag
sie fordern letztlich mustervorschriften
des bundes erstmal muss man das
verstehen ich hatte gerade mit der
kollegin hasselmann eine diskussion
darüber was überhaupt nein es ist nicht
so richtig klar geworden wozu ist aber
auch solche wir können ja nur mutmaßen
wozu es solche angesichts einer
einvernehmlichen konferenz der länder
mit der kanzlerin braucht ist schlicht
schleierhaft
wir verkennen sie die bedeutung des
bundesstaates
das grundgesetz schreibt dem bund und
den ländern kompetenzen zu unser
föderalismus ist stark und notwendig
regionale besonderheiten werden von der
landesregierung durch kommunen mit
passgenauen entscheidung in kurzen
entscheidungswegen versehen den
föderalismus durch mustervorschriften
schleifen zu wollen halte ich für nicht
zielführend sogar gefährlich eines kann
man ihnen vielleicht so am rande noch zu
geben nur weil es bundesländer gibt in
denen ministerpräsidenten das heft des
handelns in der hand haben die darum
wetteifern höhe
politische bayern zu erreichen deshalb
muss man aber nicht den föderalismus
über bord werfen finde ich die
diskussion über die einschränkungen
öffentlichen lebens haben wir vor wochen
geführt und ich frage mich warum sie
damals still gehalten haben ich kann es
ihnen erklären wer entscheidungen trifft
und vorangeht übernimmt verantwortung
mit sie wollen keine verantwortung
übernehmen für dieses und verantwortung
auch für unbeliebte maßnahmen die zum
erfolg der eindämmung der pandemie
deutlich beigetragen haben und gibt es
immer wieder aufgrund der disziplin der
menschen in diesem land mit dem stand
von heute über das gestern zu lästern
das tun sie das ist nicht redlich und
ist verkennt auch den erfolg der
bürgerinnen und bürger den sie mit viel
disziplin und hingabe erreicht haben wir
sozialdemokraten haben den grundrechten
immer abwägend geltung verschafft und
damit der zeit wirksame hygiene konzepte
und sicherheitskonzept ins werk gesetzt
das war nämlich im rahmen einer
verhältnismäßigkeit im rahmen einer
abwägung aller zweck mittel relation das
waren die abwägungen mit den
grundrechten die zu treffen war den
normalität von vor der pandemie ohne
mund nasen schutz und litern von
desinfektionsmitteln können wir nicht in
diesem parlament einfach herbei
entscheiden daher jetzt schon für eine
etwaige zweite infektionsfälle die uns
hoffentlich erspart bleibt von der sie
aber reden vorauseilend einigen
bereichen einfach absolution zu erteilen
ist der versuch faktenbasierte
entscheidungen durch glücksspiel zu
ersetzen wichtig ist mir dieser
rechtsstaat dieser sozialstaat die
kontrolle seiner demokratischen
institutionen und you durch unabhängige
gerichte war und ist in jeder phase
dieser pandemie für die bürgerinnen und
bürger erreichbar gewesen damit haben
die grundrechte immer ihren schutz gab
damit haben die grundrechte immer ihre
geltung gehabt und die gerichte bis hin
zum bundesverfassungsgericht haben ihn
auch geltung verschafft liebe kollegen
einen verwertbaren beitrag von der
fdp-fraktion bzw von der afg opposition
auf den weg zu solchen entscheidungen
habe ich noch nicht erblickt oder gehört
ich sehe das ja sie reden sie sagen viel
aber sie tun nichts es ist keine
verantwortungsübernahme was sie hier tun
sie reden über die grundrechte und
werden zugleich vom bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz beobachtet sie haben
grundrechts feindliche tendenzen in
ihren eigenen reihen und wollen diesen
deutschen bundestag erklären wie man
grundrechten geltung verschafft das muss
man den menschen darauf im land aber
auch mal erklären erklären sie doch
erstmal dem bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz wie sie es mit dem
grundgesetz halten das wäre ein anfang
in diesem haus franz müntefering hatte
einmal gesagt opposition ist mist frank
walter steinmeier führte fort und sagt
dann ist dieser mist eben dünger für die
demokratie ich setze niederrhein isfort
und sage nicht jeder dünger dass wir für
die spd ist mit dem innenausschuss und
sie sehen und hören es im hintergrund
der vorsitz im bundestag im präsidium
hat gewechselt hat hier übernommen die
bundestags vizepräsidentin und am pult
übernimmt andré hahn stellvertretender
vorsitzender der linksfraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
kein zweifel
die maßnahmen von bund und ländern geben
die korona pandemie führten zur
freiheitsbeschränkungen die
einschneidend und beispiellos sind zum
notwendigen schutz von leib und leben
wurden fundamentale grundrechte über
verordnungen und allgemeinverfügungen
von landesregierung und landräten im
eiltempo ausgesetzt ohne die parlamente
in angemessenen nennenswerten umfang zu
beteiligen
derartige zustände sind derartige
zustände sind wenn überhaupt nur
befristet hinnehmbar und deshalb
begrüßen wir es als linker das jetzt
erste lockerungen möglich sind zugleich
hoffen wir natürlich dass es keine
voreiligen schritte gibt die zu einem
erneuten an steigende infektionszahlen
führen
natürlich natürlich sind alle
demokratischen kräfte gefordert die
maßnahmen von bund und ländern kritisch
zu begleiten und permanent zu
hinterfragen bei diesem prozess der
unbedingt notwendig ist weil die
grundrechte selbstverständlich auch und
gerade in krisenzeiten gelten müssen
brauchen wir aber ganz gewiss keine
nachhilfe durch die ft und dass diese
partei die bei jeder gelegenheit gegen
muslime hetzt sich jetzt auch noch zur
verteidigerin der religionsfreiheit auf
zu spielen versucht ist geradezu grotesk
in wahrheit in wahrheit geht es der afg
nicht um grund und bürgerrechte sondern
nur darum einen vorhandenen und in
teilen auch berechtigten unmut in der
bevölkerung über manche
regierungsmaßnahmen in der korona krise
populistisch auszuschlachten das ist
einfach nur schäbig
meine damen und herren
gleichwohl gibt es reale probleme über
die wir reden müssen
gerade die schließung von schulen und
kindergärten hatte massive folgen und
damit meine ich nicht nur den betreuungs
aspekt es geht um den zugang zu bildung
es geht um das kindeswohl und hier sind
vor allem kinder aus sozial
benachteiligten familien in einer
schwierigen situation und deshalb habe
ich überhaupt kein verständnis dafür
wenn seit wochen über geisterspiele im
profifußball diskutiert wird und dafür
diverse sonderregelung ermöglicht werden
kinder auf dem bolzplatz hinter dem haus
dürfen aber weiterhin nicht fußball
spielen war das ja direkte
körperkontakte gibt wie absurd ist das
denn gestern gab es eine beratung der
kanzlerin mit den ministerpräsidenten im
übrigen ein informelles gremium ohne
jede rechtsgrundlage
dass dabei eine perspektive für hotels
und gastronomie auf die besonders die
tourismusregionen dringend warten nicht
komme bekanntlich aus der sächsischen
schweiz aufgezeigt wurde ist gleichwohl
ebenso positiv wie der umstand dass
endlich auch das thema sport auf der
tagesordnung stand das war überfällig
und viele erleichterungen für den
breitensport und die vereine begrüßen
wäre noch eine letzte bemerkung wir als
linke meinen die noch ausstehenden
geisterspiele der bundesliga müssen im
frei zugänglichen fernsehen übertragen
werden um fans zusammenballungen
um fans zusammen waren von denen die
polizei jetzt schon warum sowie privates
sky partys und damit erhöhte
infektionsrisiken zu vermeiden zudem
sollte ein drittel der noch ausstehenden
tv-einnahmen der bundesliga in einen
solidarfonds zur unterstützung der
unterklassigen vereine fließen das wäre
doch mal ein wichtiges zeichen präsident
im übrigen morgen ist der 75 jahrestag
der befreiung vom faschismus ein tag den
wir alle nie vergessen sollten
herzlichen dank andre haben für die
linksfraktion wo er stellvertretender
vorsitzender ist mit mahnenden worten am
ende nochmal morgen ist ja hier in
berlin einmalig ein feiertag zum
gedenken an den 65 jahrestag des
kriegsendes und davor mit äußerungen zum
weiterbetrieb der fußball bundesliga die
nächste rednerin ist sondern bei rahmen
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
die korona pandemie stellt uns alle vor
herausforderungen und während ich jetzt
der debatte bisher gefolgt bin habe ich
überlegt was kann ich noch wertvolles
beitragen für uns ist die situation hat
natürlich eine besondere weil wir hier
im deutschen bundestag als grüne in der
opposition sind aber in sehr vielen
bundesländern mit verschiedenen ihrer
fraktion sozusagen in der
regierungsverantwortung und deswegen
würde ich sagen meine rede ist
vielleicht
der überschrift verantwortung zu sehen
wie können wir alle gemeinsam
verantwortung übernehmen in dieser krise
die uns herausfordert wie wohl keine
bisher jedenfalls keine an die ich mich
erinnern kann
und insoweit habe ich ehrlich gesagt in
der rede der afg überhaupt nicht
verstanden was der vorschlag und die
strategie war es kann aber auch daran
liegen dass heute morgen im
morgenmagazin
ein herr müller aus der afg fraktion
verschwörungstheorien sondergleichen von
sich gegeben hat und hälse irgendwelche
polizei zum ungehorsam aufruft und man
bei der vielstimmigkeit innerhalb der
afc im prinzip gar nicht mehr weiß sind
die gefährlich oder spinnen die nur dann
laufen sie
nein ich erlasse nur fragen von
weiblichen abgeordneten der fdp
jedenfalls hat dann die frau von storch
hat deutlich gemacht dass sie sehr
darunter gelitten hat dass sie ostern
nicht feiern konnte und sich wünscht
dass sie weihnachten feiern kann
diesem wunsch können uns glaube ich alle
anschließen jeder von uns wünscht sich
geruhsame oder fröhliche oder auch wie
auch immer weihnachtsfeste in all den
jahren die uns bevorstehen
viel spannender fand ich ehrlich gesagt
die frage die die kollegin laune hat in
der runde vorher ausgeworfen hat und das
sind auch die fragen die mich erreichen
es sind die fragen in der bevölkerung
von menschen die als ein problem haben
ihren alltag zu bewältigen wo das geld
nicht mehr reicht wo der job unsicher
ist wo die zukunft der kinder unsicher
ist das sind die fragen die die menschen
beschäftigen und das sind die fragen mit
denen wir uns auseinandersetzen müssen
und die uns eigentlich zwingen zu halten
unsere gemeinsam
verantwortung für die menschen in diesem
land zu erkennen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
natürlich ist die versammlungsfreiheit
und die religionsfreiheit ein hohes gut
das wir alle schützen wollen
deswegen stellt sich auch insoweit die
frage ob es ihren antrag braucht um
diese dinge zu gewährleisten hat die
sind alle so klug wie die kollegen was
soll ich da noch ich will es dennoch
argumentativ darlegen warum ihre
zwischenrufe zu treffen sind
auf der basis des gestrigen
ministerpräsidenten beschlüsse die
länder und die von ihnen mehrfach
erwähnte bundeskanzlerin gefällt haben
wurden schon wieder an und versammlungen
auch über 20 personen hinaus erlaubt und
auch in der zwischenzeit gab es sowohl
entscheidungen des
bundesverfassungsgerichts als auch der
verwaltungsgerichte die sehr wohl
deutlich gemacht haben dass die eine
oder andere verordnung über das ziel
hinaus geschossen ist es wurde
korrigiert also können wir sagen es
braucht diesen antrag nicht weil unser
rechtsstaat auch ohne die afg sehr gut
funktioniert auch gottesdienste haben
vielfach schon stattgefunden
teilweise dürfte man dabei nicht singen
aber das beten war möglich und in hessen
nordrhein-westfalen waren ab dem ersten
und dem dritten mal und in rheinland
pfalz in berlin ebenfalls gottesdienste
möglich und das ist auch gut so weil
auch wir erkennen natürlich an dass
gerade in der krise ja wo die not groß
ist auch die sehnsucht nach beistand und
nach zusammenhalt ebenso groß ist
deswegen
könnte man hat hier feststellen im
grunde sind wir uns alle einig dass es
gut ist dass wir die balance zwischen
lockern und wieder anziehen sozusagen
also der hygiene und unserer neuen
normalität wie wir sie nennen das die
richtig und wichtig ist aber ich will
natürlich hier auch nicht verhehlen dass
es mich gewundert hat dass gerade die
afd
deutschland und die hier lebenden
menschen beleidigen will in dem
ausgerechnet sie sich anmaßen uns
nachhilfe über grundrechte zu erteilen
zu wollen
von lebensrecht über gleichheit bis
meinungsfreiheit die sie und
ihresgleichen ansonsten auch für
meinesgleichen abschaffen möchten etwa
durch hetze gegen andersdenkende oder
aussehende gegen freie medien bis hin zu
drohungen gegen andersdenkende und
mordanschläge meine damen und herren
dafür braucht es diese idee nicht die
krise hat uns sehr klar deutlich gemacht
dass dieses land rechtsstaatlich und
auch politisch viel besser aufgestellt
ist wenn sie nicht mitzureden
[Applaus]
und jetzt kommt tatsächlich eine
kurzintervention von carsten hilse aus
der fraktion da ist das schon okay
ich möchte also zurückweisen ich möchte
zurückweisen dass ich die polizisten die
ihren job machen zu ungehorsam
aufgefordert habe ich habe ein lediglich
ausgeführt dass polizisten sich nicht
auf einen sogenannten befehlsnotstand
zurückziehen können sondern
grundsätzlich persönlich verantwortlich
gemacht werden für ihre handlungen
ich möchte sie also bewahren vor
zukünftigen verurteilungen unter
umständen und festgelegt bzw was
polizisten dann machen sollten wenn sie
zumindest vermuten dass es eine
rechtswidrige dienstliche anordnung ist
das habe ich aus geführt und da gibt es
das bundesbeamten gesetz § 63 und
gleichlautend das beamtenstatusgesetz §
33 gibt die so genannte demonstrations-
pflicht das heißt der beamte wenn er
vermutet dass die anordnung die
dienstliche anordnung zumindest
rechtswidrig oder teilweise rechtswidrig
ist dann hat er das seinem vorgesetzten
zu melden oder anzumelden und wenn er
dann sagt die dienstliche anordnung gilt
trotzdem hat das dem nächsten
vorgesetzten zu melden oder anzumelden
diese bedenken und dann ist kann er
sozusagen nicht mehr erfordert werden
dann ist er seine remonstranten
nachgekommen
und natürlich geht es mir nicht darum
polizisten zu ungehorsam aufzufordern
oder polizisten schlechte mache ich bin
drei über 30 jahre polizist gewesen es
geht mir darum ersten polizisten dazu
aufzufordern unnötige härte gegen
menschen die für ihre freiheit auf die
straße gehen friedlich auf die straße
gehen zu unterlassen und die spaltung
die im moment gerade passiert weil
polizisten eben teilweise rechtswidrige
anordnungen durchführen muss
zwischen volk und polizei zu verhindern
ich möchte das ist es polizisten dazu
auffordern unnötige härte und
gleichzeitig aber auch verständnis bei
den friedlichen demonstranten für die
polizei wecken
darum ging es mir nicht um positionen zu
ungeordnet sich zum produzierenden zwei
minuten überschritten frau waren wollen
sie antreten ja vielen dank frau
präsidentin in aller kürze will ich
antworten weil ich das hier mit herrn
amthor beraten habe und für gemeinsam
übereingekommen sind dass die polizisten
vielleicht besser auf juristen hören als
auf einen abgeordneten der fdp fraktion
kritik auf die intervention von carsten
hilse dessen offener brief übrigens an
die polizistinnen und polizisten mit dem
satz endet steht auf der seite des
volkes denn auch ihr seid das volk
nächster redner hier dieser debatte ist
christoph berndt stil aus der
unionsfraktion es geht um zwei anträge
der afd die wir gegen gemäss
zusammenzufassen sind mit dem titel
rückkehr in die normalität und eine
kleine ergänzung noch eine kleine
information noch zum geschehen außerhalb
des plenarsaals da bleibt es wohl dabei
dass die wahlgänge die wir schon
wiederholt angesprochen haben bis 14 uhr
10 14 uhr elfen sehen so dann wird
ausgezählt und dann werden wir wohl
mindestens 30 bis 45 minuten warten
müssen bis die ersten ergebnisse hier
eintrudeln denn es ist ja eine ganze
menge auszuzählen das also in der stand
der dinge am fahrplan hat sich nichts
geändert und deswegen gehen wir jetzt
fix wieder rein in den plenarsaal
das ist schäbig wäre angst in die top
ten steht diese zu benutzen um
irgendwelche rechte einzuschränken und
genau das machen sie jetzt mit ihrem
antrag in dem sie hier wie es kollege
anto der heute schon häufig erwähnt
wurde erwähnt hat
teil schon fakten verbreiten und einfach
eine stimmung erzeugen die sich so nicht
hält aber wenn sie von problemen reden
beziehungsweise einen missbrauch der
durch diese app entstehen kann dann ist
das auch bemerkenswert und zweierlei
hinsicht
sie beziehen sich in ihrem antrag
ausgerechnet auf eine anfrage der partei
die linke die ähnlich immer wieder um
unsere sicherheitsorgane kritisiert ohne
hier das augenmaß und pauschal ein
missbrauch jeglicher kompetenzen
unterstellt das machen sie in ihrem
antrag auch und das denen ich ab es
zeigt aber erneut wie nah sich doch die
beiden pole sind was sie ja immer wieder
leugnen und dann und dann schauen wir
uns doch mal an wie datenmissbrauch mit
so einer app tatsächlich funktionieren
kann und erstaunlicherweise ausgerechnet
bei ihrem populistischen freunden in
polen können wir ja sehr gut beobachten
wie so eine app nicht funktionieren soll
dort ist es nämlich so jeder ist
verpflichtet der sich mit diesen corona
virus infiziert hat diese app zu nutzen
diese daten werden weitergegeben an die
polizei sie müssen wenn sie die
aufforderung bekommen 111 ii von sich an
die polizeibehörden posten tun sie dies
nicht so können sie festgenommen werden
dieses elfi muss im umkreis von 100
metern um ihrem wohnort aufgenommen sein
und die daten werden bis zu sechs jahren
gespeichert
nicht viel besser sieht es aus in
russland dort gibt es ebenfalls eine
pflicht mit den ähnlichen funktionen und
dazu kommen natürlich noch checkpoints
wo sie qr-codes auf ihrem handy wenn der
georg muth nicht gültig ist dürfen sie
gewisse bereiche der stadt nicht
betreten hinzu noch gewürzt mit einer
prise gesichts überwachung so
funktioniert das in autoritären staaten
und china erkennen sich wahrscheinlich
bestens aus brauchen wir hier gar nicht
zu reden dass wir das so in deutschland
nicht wollen und dass das auch niemand
geplant hat das ist konsens ihren
gesamten haus und das mittlerweile auch
bei allen angekommen nur scheinbar bei
ihnen nicht ich möchte ich möchte an
dieser stelle aber auch mal dann danke
sagen denn sie geben uns jetzt hier die
gelegenheit das thema app noch mal einer
ausführlichkeit darzustellen und einige
fake news und einige dinge unterhalten
die jetzt verbreitet wurden
jemals zu klären ich möchte etwas sagen
zu den funktionen der app worum geht es
eigentlich es geht da um
infektionsketten rekonstruieren zu
können und die
verbreitungsgeschwindigkeit das virus
eindämmen zu können indem ihm frühzeitig
warnungen ausgesprochen werden das sind
die zwei kernfunktionen dieser app und
hinzu kommt dann noch wenn es gewünscht
ist von den nutzern das ist ja ein ganz
entscheidendes kriterium dass man mehr
über das virus selbst erfahren kann zum
beispiel über die verbreitungswege oder
auch über die aufbereitete dunkelziffer
und in diesem zusammenhang gab es
verschiedene ansätze die bereits auf
verfolgt worden
sie alle haben sicherlich den
europäischen ansatz verfolgt und es gibt
auch diskussionen was gut richtig und
vollkommen normal ist in einem
rechtsstaat
über die frage des datenschutzes und den
schutz der privatsphäre und was sie
lieber fdp kritisieren als versagen der
regierung das ist nicht gelungen ist
diese schnellstmöglich auf den weg zu
bringen das würde ich bezeichnen als
qualitatives arbeiten und das vorgehen
mit der gebotenen sorgfalt und so eine
wichtige app auf den weg zu bringen und
genau auf diesem weg befinden wir uns
gerade ein ganz wesentliches kriterium
ist es so genannte prinzip der doppelten
freiwilligkeit
das heißt wenn diese app kommt dann ist
sie für jeden freiwillig zu installieren
und es ist auch freiwillig dass sie dann
diese daten spende machen
beziehungsweise ob sie überhaupt eine
meldung in dieser app eingeben das ist
ein ganz fundamentales prinzip
unterscheidet die app den deutschen
ansatz von vielen anderen ansätzen auf
der welt und auch leider muss man sagen
in europa ich will aber auch noch auf 1
hinweisen weil es ja auch einige
kritiker und diesem zusammenhang gibt
welche probleme sich aus dem vergleich
zwischen zentralen und dezentralen
ansatz ergeben
ein maßgeblicher punkt den wir
besprechen müssen ist das thema fehlern
stellen sie sich mal vor sie nutzen
jetzt diese app sind mit dieser app
unterwegs die m registriert die kontakte
natürlich anonymisiert und dann
sie sich einen spaß und bösen fehler aus
den kriegen im schlimmsten fall sondern
großstadt wie berlin mehrere tausend
menschen die möglichkeit die meldung 8
und corona infizierung in ihrem umfeld
bitte begeben sich zum arzt oder gehen
sie gleichen quarantäne
das geht es natürlich zu vermeiden und
für diese für diesen prozess brauchen
wir dringend eine schnittstelle die
überprüft ist derjenige der den alarm
auslöst tatsächlich infiziert
die gute nachricht ist da kann man viel
machen mit anonymisierten pin-codes man
kann dort lockte ihn einsetzen
alles ist möglich aber dieses problem
dürfen wir nicht aus dem auge verlieren
und nicht ganz einfach sagen nur der
dezentrale ansatz löst alle probleme
dann nochmal zu der frage der
freiwilligkeit hier wird ja häufig
infrage gestellt dass das mit der
freiwilligkeit überhaupt nicht
funktioniert an dass die deutschen das
überhaupt nicht möchten da gibt es wird
sei dank einige erkenntnisse und zwar
gibt es ja bereits die daten spende app
des robert-koch-instituts zugegeben am
anfang mit einigen startschwierigkeiten
aber es gab immerhin 400 tausend
freiwillige deutsche die an diesem an
dieser daten spende teilgenommen haben
am fitness daten gespendet so war unter
angabe ihrer postleitzahl und
gleichzeitig hat der bayerische rundfunk
anfang april eine umfrage durchgeführt
die exklusive äußerst interessante
lieber auf die kollegen und zwar wurden
dort 10.000 teilnehmer gefragt wie es
denn überhaupt halten würden sie so eine
app benutzen ja oder nein
56 prozent gaben an dass sie diese app
nutzen würden jetzt sagt die umfrage
geht noch ein bisschen tiefer rein und
beleuchtet welche anhänger welcher
partei eigentlich einer nutzung dieser
app zu stimmen beziehungsweise auch
hohes vertrauen sähen überraschend die
höchste zustimmung geben die
unionswähler mit 71 prozent auch die
grünen sonst eigentlich immer sehr
kritisch bei solchen fragen bestimmt mit
62 prozent zu und 59 prozent sind es bei
der spd bei der afd sind es
erstaunlicherweise ist es denn mit
abstand der niedrige werte nur 27
prozent der auf dem wir noch stimmen
einer verwendung dieser app zu und das
spiegelt sich auch in ihrem antrag
wieder und ich möchte zum schluss noch
sagen wenn sie fordern diese app nicht
einzusetzen
dann sind sie
die nächsten shutter und promotion denn
wir brauchen diese app um lokal präzise
eingrenzen zu können wo sich
infektionsketten ausbreiten wir brauchen
diese app auch um auf dem nächsten virus
der sicherlich kommen wird vorbereitet
zu sein und wir brauchen diese app um
die verhältnismäßigkeit in zukunft auch
gewährleisten zu können und prozesse
eingreifen zu können wenn sie diese app
einlegt ablehnen dann leben sie auch
alle diese sinnvollen maßnahmen ab und
deshalb werden die auch ihrem antrag
ablehnen ablehnen und zum schluss möchte
ich noch sagen wir haben das grundgesetz
schon verteidigt da hat es ihre partei
noch nicht die gegend gegen rechts und
links wir brauchen von ihm keine
belehrung und machen sich keine sorgen
wir werden es auch in zukunft
verteidigen wenn sie hoffentlich nicht
mehr in diesem haus sitzen
herzlichen dank verstehen dass für die
unionsfraktion ist auch mitglied im
innenausschuss und hat natürlich noch
mal reagiert auf die beiden anträge die
die erklären diese zu diesen gebieten
punkt vorgelegt hat und das gibt mir mal
schnell die gelegenheit darauf
hinzuweisen dass ist heute am frühen
nachmittag wie mal daumen und 14 uhr
eine weltpremiere geben wird in diesem
parlament ein gesetzentwurf dem
mutmaßlich so gut wie alle bbl zustimmen
werden logischerweise auch jeweils die
große mehrheit in allen fraktionen es
geht nicht um die aussetzung der
diätenerhöhung damit tatsächlich alle
mal dafür stimmen also auch die
fdp-fraktion einer querbeet durchs ganze
plenum das dann doch mal was neues hier
im hohen hauses und jetzt waren wir
johanna kutter aus der fraktion zu
begehen wollen sie jetzt sparen das
auswerten von standortdaten zur
bekämpfung von kobe 19 feldspieler
einzigen das tun sich der
informationellen selbstbestimmung und
technisch sinnlos noch dazu
der aufschrei groß genug dass er den
plan zurückziehen musste jetzt sollen es
die apps echten zur tracing hebt gesellt
sich plötzlich die daten spende app des
rk ii
neben anderen soll jetzt eine
quantitative existieren eine notiz aus
weiß app war auch im gespräch
die regierung
schlicht die sich diese auszunutzen und
zu sehen wie weit sie gehen können
bevor die bürger endgültig genug haben
anders ist diese szene von
freiheitsrechten nicht zu erklären
zu beginn setzten die regierung bei der
2011 auf den zentralen server ansatz
daraufhin wandten 300 wissenschaftler
von renommierten universitäten vor einer
möglichen beispiellosen überwachung
die bundesregierung hielt trotzdem an
den zentralen ansatz fest die big water
idee war eben zu reizvoll
erst als sich die pikanten google und
apple querstellten musste die regierung
den plan aufgeben
jetzt soll es also der dezentrale ansatz
richten wie genau wissen wir noch nicht
wir durften im ausschuss digital agenda
feststellen dass es keinen zeitplan gibt
kein budget keine verantwortlichen der
datenschutz ist noch nicht geklärt
die technischen probleme schon gar nicht
es gab keinerlei persönlichen gespräche
mit apple die mit dafür verantwortlich
sind dass dieser überhaupt funktionieren
kann
es gibt keinen exit plan und das
allerwichtigste es gibt keinerlei pläne
der regierung die nicht erbt nutzer vor
sozialer diskriminierung zu schützen
diese app muss wenn sie denn kommt
absolut transparent und freiwillig sein
und es darf nicht passieren dass man
eben nicht mit den supermarktketten darf
oder nicht mehr zur arbeit gehen kann
wenn man die app nicht nutzt dass es
nicht soweit kommt liegt in ihrer
verantwortung die regierung machen sie
ihren job im moment tun sie das genaue
gegenteil aus den reihen der csu kam der
vorschlag die grundrechte an die nutzung
der app truppe was für ein absurd
gefährlicher gedanke ebenso die idee die
leute mit steuererleichterungen zu
locken
grundrechte kann man nicht verkaufen
liebe kollegen eine app ist keinerlei
mit
sie ersetzt keine hygienemaßnahmen es
ist nicht einmal bewiesen dass überhaupt
biologisch sinnvoll ist singapur das
lange zeit als vorbild guard erlebte
eine erschreckende zweite welle trotzen
aber das ist die schöne neue welt der
regierung wir sollen uns eben an die
überwachung gewöhnen
und wenn ich genug bürger mitmachen
kommt nach der freiwilligkeit der zwang
und sei es durch soziale ausgrenzung der
städte und landkreistag forderte bereits
umfangreichen zugriff auf mögliche
gesammelte daten
die polizei hat sie schon siehe
baden-württemberg die fdp diese
eingriffe in die bürgerrechte konsequent
ab im zweifel immer für die freiheit
daher fordern wir die regierung auf die
pläne zu stoppen
machen sie ein hauptmann konzentrieren
sie sich auf das was wirklich hilft
finden wir einen weg zur normalität ohne
bespitzelung ohne die freigabe der
bürgerrechte dafür aber mit gesundem
menschenverstand
die fdp fraktion und der nächste redner
in dieser debatte in der es wie schon
gesagt um zwei anträge der ard geht ist
der sebastian hartmann aus der
spd-fraktion landesvorsitzender
westfalen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die korona
handle me fordert uns als gesellschaft
aber auch als parlament wir sind
allerdings nicht das erste mal mit einer
solchen pandemie globalen ausmaßes
konfrontiert wir sind auch in der
vergangenheit
mit einer hongkong-grippe konfrontiert
gewesen oder gar vor über 100 jahren
schon mit der spanischen grippe
allerdings meine damen und herren
sollten wir uns daran erinnern dass jede
dieser termin und jeder der
herausforderung der wir als gesellschaft
und auch als staaten begegnet sind wir
haben sie überwunden
wir haben sie überwunden wir waren in
der lage vor allen dingen zwei dinge in
den weg genommen
wir haben auf der einen seite
fortschritt und wissenschaft die uns
leiten können in einer verantwortung die
wir als parlament aufnehmen und abwägen
müssten nicht jedem expertenrat zu
folgen und das andere ist und das
entscheidende in diesem moment aber
erfolg den wir nun sehen was die
infektionszahlen angeht die eindämmung
dieser pandemie in diesem land es ist
nicht das alleinige handeln einer
regierung oder eines ministerpräsidenten
oder der kanzlerin allein es ist eine
gemeinsame aufgabe die wir in diesem
land hinbekommen haben und dafür gilt
der dank an all diejenigen menschen in
diesem land die bürgerinnen und bürger
die sich verantwortungsvoll gezeigt
haben vor allen dingen solidarisch weil
wir aufeinander acht gegeben haben weil
wir regeln der hygiene eingehalten haben
weil wir dafür gesorgt haben dass eben
sich infektionszahlen nicht weiter
ausbreiten und nicht die entscheidende
frage war ob man selbst zu einer risiko
oder ob man selbst in der gefahr ist zu
erkranken sondern auf den anderen auch
acht zu geben denn risiko und hier für
meinen herzlichen dank meine damen und
herren das ist das fundament dieses
erfolges
und dann sind wir bei der gefahr die nun
versucht wird in diesem haus zu streuen
sagt des zweifels hast hetze und spalte
fake news in dem versucht wird
erkenntnisse die wir schon erreicht
haben während dieser pandemie durch
diffamierung von experten durch das
teilen von fay games oder das stellen
von absurden anträgen und behauptungen
die jeder grundlage entbehren eben diese
seite zweifel zu säen
weil sie gefährden das vertrauen das man
in der demokratie immer wieder neu
gegründet und die sozialdemokratie ist
unverdächtig dass wir freiheitsrechte
und grundrechte einschränken und wir
haben in aller klarheit
auch gesagt weniger pressekonferenzen
weniger interne besprechung mehr debatte
im parlament das ist die stunde des
parlamentes meine damen und herren und
eine debatte wie heute zeigt auch den
wohl abgewogenen beiträgen dass wir
genau das tun und darauf können sich die
bürgerinnen und bürger in diesem land
verlassen dass wir verantwortungsvoll
mit dieser situation umgehen
die angesprochene sie ist etwas was ein
hilfsmittel sein kann um über corona zu
lernen und zu erfahren aber für uns als
sozialdemokratie gilt kein zentraler
ansatz sondern dezentrale ansatz
maximaler datenschutz und werden diese
debatten nicht nur schon mit dieser
corona ich habe den kollegen von der fdp
zugehört als sie für die grundrechte die
freiheitsrechte geworben haben und ich
fand viele teile ihrer ausführung
wirklich absolut zustimmungsfähig das
war auch der grund warum wir in
nordrhein-westfalen der schwarz gelben
regierung in den arm gefallen sind als
sie ein pandemie gesetz beschließen
wollte das passende wie gesetz nutzen
wollte um zwangsrekrutierung vom
medizinischen personal wissen zur
beschlagnahme vorzunehmen die fdp
unangenehm auf der regierungsbank hin
und her rutscht und sagte das geht zu
weit
und sie hatten recht und deswegen haben
wir das auch verhindert in nordrhein
westfalen und es ist jetzt in der
weiteren debatte auch klar zu machen
dass nicht unser weg sein letzter
gedanke zu dieser app mein letzter
gedanke ihr habt euch entschieden für
die regierungsbeteiligung der union das
ist eure verantwortung aber ein gedanke
zu rap wir reden über eine corona app
der gesundheitsminister schon für mitte
april angekündigt hat bevor er überhaupt
schnittstellen zwischen google und apple
klar waren wir vor der zentrale der
zentrale ansatz gesprochen worden
aber wir haben doch schon eine app 2015
eingeführt das ist die nina bahn app die
das bundesamt für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe zur verfügung stellt
wird einer vielzahl von hinweisen wie
man ideen achten kann auf den nächsten
acht gibt und ich werbe dafür das ist
das entscheidende in unserer demokratie
in einem demokratischen transparent
rechts schauen wir auf die information
und schauen wir darauf was wir zur
verfügung stellt auch auf den
expertenrat er sich möglicherweise
widerspricht aber das ist doch der
moment wo wir objektiv informieren
wollen und werden sich ein einziges mal
den anschein erweckt dass wir nicht mit
fortschritte erkenntnisse auch dinge die
wir als grundlage formulierter
möglicherweise in frage stellen oder
noch mal verändern
derjenige der behauptet alles zu anfangs
zu wissen wo er mit einer neuen und
unbekannten situation konfrontiert ist
dem darf man nicht glauben in dieser
situation liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und deswegen bevor die korona ab in
welcher form auch immer kommt
installieren sie doch die nina bahn ab
und informieren sie sich wie die lage in
ihrem landkreis in ihrer stadt ist das
ist doch schon verfügbar und hier
arbeiten bund und länder hervorragend
zusammen
liebe kolleginnen und die ausübung der
religionsfreiheit ist auch angesprochen
worden
die einschränkung den parteien sich auch
freiwillig unterworfen haben die kirchen
und religionsgemeinschaften in unserem
land das sind alles massive eingriffe
und ich glaube dass wir in der folge
auch erkennen müssen dass ganz viel
erreicht worden ist durch freiwilliges
verhalten eben im vertrauen auf
staatliche stellen und parlamente die
ihrer verantwortung nachkommen auch der
kritischen abwägen
das ist das was wir bürgerinnen und
bürger gemeinsam geschaffen es ist
gesprochen worden davon dass weihnachten
gemeinsam gefeiert werden soll
aber wir sind doch nicht voneinander
gegangen sondern wir haben doch gerade
jetzt in diesem moment versucht
solidarisch und zusammenhalten zu sein
weil ich kirchen haben das getan aber
der rednerin hier im hause die über
weihnachten sprach er möchte ich doch
eher das pfingstfest empfehlen auf dass
sie ihre erkenntnisse ableiten und auch
mal darum sehen solange sie in ihren
reihen verfassungsfeinde dulden das
grundgesetz in frage stellen die rechten
von der afd solange dürfen sie niemanden
hier im haus irgendwie belehren was die
geltung unserer grundrechte und des
grundgesetzes angeht sebastian herrmann
war das für die spd fraktion und der
nächste redner wird sein benjamin
strasser und er kommt aus der fdp
fraktion und dann ist auch diese debatte
bald schon ob frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen millionen von
gläubigen menschen in deutschland egal
ob christen juden muslime erleben
momentan harte zeiten
das osterfest ist in beiden teilen
ausgefallen genau wie die perser feiern
und auch der ramadan kann nicht wie
gewohnt stattfinden bei alldem handelt
es sich um massive eingriffe in die
religionsausübung die wir hier auch im
deutschen bundestag sprechen müssen und
in dieser situation kommt jetzt ein
antrag der afg auf den tisch der ein
bemerkenswertes verständnis von
religionsfreiheit offenbart wenn es nach
dieser partei geht zu lesen die am
antrag ist nämlich in corona zeiten
religionsfreiheit nur für christen
gestattet sie sprechen in ihrem antrag
von pauschalen verboten von
ostergottesdiensten aber kein wort zu
papa feiern oder dem ramadan
sie sorgen sich um weihnachten 2020 ob
jüdinnen und juden in diesem land
hannover feiern können ist ihm
offensichtlich egal
und dieses verhältnis zur
religionsfreiheit ist entlaufen
sie benützen
die jungs freiheit nur dann wenn es in
ihre politische agenda pass kostet wenn
man sich zuvor den von jüdinnen und
juden generiert wenn es gegen muslime
geht aber sonst zählen diese menschen
für sie offensichtlich nichts und das
ist auch nicht der geist des
grundgesetzes im grundgesetz gilt
religionsfreiheit für alle menschen und
dahinter stehen wir freie demokraten
ganz ausdrücklich aber an tor hat er
recht reden ja weniger wie die reden wir
über das verhalten der bundesregierung
in der letzten zeit und sie werden in
ihrem grundrecht kommentar sich schon
festgestellt haben was da steht nämlich
dass gläubige in ihrem glauben und wie
sie diesen glauben ausleben dem staat
grundsätzlich nichts zusteht
hierüber zu verfügen und in der
disposition der mehrheitsgesellschaft
irgendwelche änderungen an diesem
glauben vorzunehmen und genau deshalb
gab es auch die entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts am zehnten
april das nicht nur festgestellt hat
dass diese gottesdienst vorbote
schwerwiegende grundrechtseingriffe sind
sondern die auch festgestellt hat dass
es eine andauernde überprüfung dieser
maßnahmen gibt und ich kann da nur der
vorsitzende der deutschen
bischofskonferenz zustimmen der sich
sehr enttäuscht gezeigt hat was die
bundeskanzlerin fünf tage nach dieser
entscheidung beschlossen hat ja alle
religionsgemeinschaften in deutschland
jüdinnen und juden christen muslime
haben durch die bank sehr kooperativ
diese maßnahmen mitgetragen
in der korona krise dass sie frau
bundeskanzlerin am 15 april dann aber
kfz händler öffnen lässt und die
kleinste ladengeschäfte und
sicherheitsvorkehrungen aber
gottesdienstbesuche nicht gestartet das
kann nicht sein und das ist ein massiver
eingriff in die glaubensfreiheit dieser
menschen glaubensfreiheit liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
heißt nicht und die es aber nicht damit
genüge getan dass jeder an das glauben
darf was er will
aber bitte daheim sondern dass man
seinen glauben auch ausleben kann
gottesdienste sind kein nice to have
sondern wesentliche teil eine grund
rechtsausübung und deswegen muss klar
sein in der zukunft dass solche
entscheidungen wie es die
bundesregierung getroffen hat so nicht
mehr vorkommt sondern dass die
religionsfreiheit für alle menschen in
diesem land gewährleistet bleibt vielen
herzlichen dank
vielen dank benjamin strasser herzlichen
dank nächster redner für die fraktion
die linke niema movassat frau
präsidentin meine damen und herren die
korona krise machte und macht
staatliches handeln notwendig und
dennoch ist es wichtig auch in dieser
situation über sich über grundrechte
gedanken zu machen
wir erleben die heftigsten
einschränkungen von grundrechten seit
dem bestehen des grundgesetzes wir
erleben die regierung per
rechtsverordnung einschneidende
maßnahmen beschließen ohne dass die
parlamente was zu sagen haben der ihr
leben dass bundesminister rote linien
überschreiten die gesundheitsminister
sparen mit seiner erneuten novelle des
infektionsschutzgesetzes und
besorgniserregend ist wie die
grundrechte und der rechtsstaat
teilweise zu einem spielball im kampf um
den cdu vorsitz geworden sind einige
ministerpräsidenten auf diese weise ihre
fragile männlichkeit miteinander und
gegeneinander aus therapieren
verantwortungsvoll ist das alles nicht
in dieser gemengelage kommt der
opposition eine wichtige rolle zu es sei
denn ein teil der opposition versucht
die ratlosigkeit vieler menschen in
dieser zeit zu müssen
es sei denn ein teil dieser opposition
greift von diesem plenum muss ständig
die menschenwürde an in dem sie
geflüchtete verächtlich macht schule und
dessen beleidigt und frauenrechte
zurückdrehen will
und dieser teil das ist die afd sie sind
die partei ihr verhältnis zur ns zeit in
deutschland immer noch nicht geklärt
haben die partei deren fraktionschef
gauland ernsthaft meint der morgige
achte mai der tag der befreiung
deutschlands sei ein tag der niederlage
ja die nazis war sein tag der niederlage
da weiß man wo sie sich politisch ein
rein und ich jedenfalls bin froh dass
das rot rot grün regierte berlin den 8
zum feiertag erklärt hat wer die
befreiung nicht feiert derart verloren
und sich die achte heute im bundestag
hinstellt und von grundrechten redet
dann muss man sagen das ist an heuchelei
nicht mehr zu überbieten
dass die grundrechte nur für einige
menschen wollen das zeigt doch ihr
herangehen an die religionsfreiheit in
ihrem antrag
sie fordern religiöse feste wie ostern
pfingsten weihnachten trotz corona zu
feiern
aber das pessachfest oder ramadan
fehlanzeige in ihrem antrag wollen
religionsfreiheit nur für das
christentum
sie können das offenbar nicht ertragen
dass in diesem plan auch juden und
muslime leben und rechte haben wir
werden als linke für ein deutschland
kämpfen in dem alle menschen gleiche
rechte haben
zudem müssen sie sich als 18 mal
entscheiden ob sie wirklich die rechte
fake news blase bedienen wollen dass die
das corona virus auf die leichte
schulter nimmt oder gar leugnet so
behauptete ihr abgeordneter müller die
in den corona stadtbewohner statistik
würden andere tote untergeschoben und
die statistik um die statistik nach oben
zu jubeln was für eine ecke geworden war
erklären sie doch mal wer warum
todeszahlen nach oben manipuliert haben
soll
dieses haus braucht
die fdp deren ganzes produktprogramm auf
der ausgrenzung von menschen beruht
nicht um sich grundrechte erklären zu
lassen
nicht die korona krise ist die größte
gefahr für die grundrechte in diesem
land sondern die afg ist die größte
gefahr für die grundrechte danke schön
wie immer movassat war das für die
installation und irgendwie eine kleine
korrektur schuldig weil wir haben ja so
furchtbar aufmerksame zuschauer als ich
wollte die welt regieren in diesem
parlament ein einstimmiger beschluss
über alle fraktionen da muss man für
dieses parlament das nämlich hier
wirklich alle fraktionen gemeinsam einem
gesetzentwurf zustimmen dass dadurch das
besondere natürlich darin dass auch
daran hier die kfd beteiligt dessen
natürlich gab es schon in früheren
jahren einstimmige beschlüsse hier im
deutschen bundestag so da habe ich
schnell mal nach geschoben weil unser
publikum ebenso aufmerksam ist und
deswegen ganz schnell weiter wieder
zurück in wembley nasa alter spricht
kino sorge für die unions fraktion reden
sie von george orwells 1984 oder denen
sie von der tv trash sendung wo es um
container dürfe geht aber wir sollten
uns alle mal daran erinnern
corona es keine tv show koma ist kein
altes buch was war einfach zur seite
legen können und gegen korona gibt es
nun mal noch keine impfung und deshalb
glaube ich wäre es auch angebracht auch
angesichts der menschen leben die cola
fordert letztendlich dem thema nicht
solche merkwürdigen vergleiche
angedeihen zu lassen aber zur sache
quer durch alle fraktionen haben wir in
den letzten wochen darüber diskutiert
wie der cola oder das corona die ruß
effizient bekämpft werden kann und da
haben wir uns natürlich auch über
digitale möglichkeiten unterhalten ging
es um die tracing app die uns helfen
soll infektionsketten besser
nachzuvollziehen
und da kann man sich natürlich darüber
streiten wie wird diese konkrete app
ausgestaltet was hat man für
unterschiedliche auffassungen
aber was machen sie sie kommen wieder
mit kruden verschwörungstheorien corona
wäre
nur eine verhältnismäßig leichte grippe
oder bill gates hat das alles mit
getriggert super idee jetzt kann will
geht es endlich mal reich werden indem
man mit seinen stoffen geld verdient und
klar die regierung hat natürlich die
ganzen grundrechte außer kraft gesetzt
aber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
der ard ich empfehle ihnen wirklich mal
gehen sie in die gesundheitsämter
schauen sie sich an wie dort
recherchiert wird wie corona fälle
nachrecherchiert werden das ist
detektivarbeit das ist sehr mühsam wie
es dort recherchiert wird und deshalb
glaube ich verlieren wir wertvolle zeit
im kampf gegen das virus und das virus
als gegner hat sowieso schon vorsprung
deshalb sollten wir auch so lange es
keinen impfstoff gibt solche digitalen
möglichkeiten nutzen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
und deshalb ist es ja auch gut dass wir
nach modernen lösungen suchen dass wir
innovationspotenziale dabei mit
einbeziehen und insofern glaube ich
schon dass die möglichkeiten von apps ob
das jetzt tracing oder tracking ist da
kann uns streiten in welchem umfang das
ausgestaltet da können wir über
datenschutz schreiben da können wir uns
über abwägung von grundrechten sehr gern
streiten und deshalb unterstützen wir
auch als union den ansatz mit apps
epidemien möglichst zeitnahe zumindest
dann aber die kommenden epidemien besser
nachverfolgen zu können
aber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
was hier mit diesem afd antrag sie als
afc wieder gemacht haben ist ja nichts
anderes als dass ihre hausaufgaben nicht
gemacht haben beim lesen des antrages
fällt einem ja schon auf sie kriegen es
ja nicht mal unfallfreien in den namen
der staatsministerin für digitales
richtig zu schreiben
die heißt nicht dorothea bär sondern
dorothee bär sie kriegen es nicht mal
hin zwischen tracing und trekking zu
differenzieren
also insofern stellt sich die frage ist
das jetzt dummheit oder ist das bewusste
irreführung was sie hier machen und der
antrag ist ja auch in sich
widersprüchlich da stellen sie heute den
antrag und sagen nein zu corona apps
nein zur datensammlung durch corona apps
und gestern stellt sich ihr kollege
spangenberg ich weiß nicht wo er steht
im gesundheitsausschuss
hinstellt drei afg an tragen die genau
das gegenteil vortragen die vorderen
dann so dinge die korona digital
bekämpfen und sie sie fordern ja schauen
sie sich doch mal an genau in den
anträgen steht das prinzip drei anträge
sie sollten der fraktion vielleicht mal
miteinander sprechen und insofern ist es
echt putzig sie fordern heute das
gegenteil dessen was sie gestern im
ausschuss für gesundheit gefordert haben
ja ich zitiere mal das schreiben sie zum
beispiel digitalisierung sei ein gutes
instrument digitale
innovationspotenziale müssen
ausgeschöpft werden auch durch apps
digitale lösungen via smartphone könnten
besonders in der aktuellen lage schnell
für entlastung sorgen
das heißt im gesundheitsausschuss
präsentieren sie sich als die großen
digital politiker sie präsentieren sich
als die innovations- geister des
parlaments und dann stellen sie sich
hierhin ins parlament und schüren die
angst vor apps grundrechte würden außer
kraft gesetzt die regierung plane
verschwörungs potenzial also das ist
nicht nur widersprüchlich das ist
absolute volksverdummung zeichen ganz
offen
unsere sache wir werden auch digitale
möglichkeiten auch in form von apps
natürlich in hand so haben sie es aber
keine zeit mehr das auszufüllen der
diskussion hier im parlament führen ich
freue mich dass wir das vielleicht ein
bisschen sachlicher und weniger angst
sondern chancen getrieben machen werden
das wird der akzeptanz auf solche
möglichkeiten gut tun
und das tut glaub ich uns allen vielen
dank nächster und letzter redner in der
debatte in dieser debatte
vielen herzlichen dank stefan will dinge
für die cdu/csu-fraktion pilgerbüro
präsidentin meine damen und herren unser
gemeinsamer einsatz zeigt die erste
erfolge dank der ergriffenen maßnahmen
konnten wir die ausbreitung des virus in
den vergangenen wochen entscheiden
verlangsamen diesen vorsprung dürfen wir
jetzt nicht leichtfertig vergeuden wir
befinden uns in einer phase in der wir
unsere wirtschaft und unser soziales
zusammen
neben behutsam wieder hochfahren können
das bedeutet nicht dass wir sofort in
unserem gewohnten alltag zurückkehren
können im gegenteil wenn wir nun
unvorsichtig werden verspielen wir haben
ende die mühsam erkämpften fortschritte
ganz entscheidend für das weitere
vorgehen ist die kapazität unserer
kliniken mit unsere maßnahmen haben wir
erreicht dass jeder corona patient in
deutschland zu jeder zeit bestmöglich
versorgt werden konnte und versorgt
werden kann und das muss auch wirklich
so bleiben
das behutsame hochfahren bedeutet für
die krankenhäuser wenn sie freie
kapazitäten haben sollen die geplante
operation in behandlung auch wieder
durchführen können
an dieser stelle möchte ich mich daher
ausdrücklich beim gesundheitsminister
dafür bedanken dass er bereits mit
hochdruck an einem konzept für einen
neuen alltag und in kliniken arbeitet um
die kliniken bei der bewältigung der
aufgaben bestmöglich zu unterstützen
denken wir jetzt auch über neue wege zur
nachverfolgung von infektionsketten nach
künftig sollten unsere zahlreichen
engagierten containment scouts in
gesundheitsämtern dabei hilfe von einer
app bekommen und eine solche app könnte
ein entscheidendes element unserer
künftigen strategie zur bekämpfung des
virus werden
das wird sie aber nur dann wenn
möglichst viele mitmachen und ich betone
an dieser stelle ausdrücklich die
nutzung der app ist freiwillig und sie
wird auch freiwillig bleiben die daten
der nutzer sollen dabei stets dezentral
auf den geräten gespeichert werden damit
sie nicht vor dem zugriff von außen
damit sie besser vor dem zugriff von
außen geschützt bleiben eine
aufzeichnung oder auswertung von
gps-daten standorten findet nicht statt
auch die funktionsweise der apps soll
für alle nachvollziehbar sein
nur wenn wir den bürgerinnen und bürgern
jetzt vermitteln können dass die nutzung
einer solchen app sicher ist werden wir
auf eine ausreichende verbreitung
erreichen können unbegründete panikmache
wie sie das hier in ihrem antrag
versuchen ist eindeutig fehl am platz
und schreckt die menschen einfach nur
unnötig
je mehr wir alle künftig von solchen
technologien gebrauch machen desto mehr
menschen können wir schützen das du
schneller können wir in unserem
gewohnten alltag zurückkehren
und diese ziele meine damen und herren
können wir hier denke ich alle
unterstützen
vielen dank spielen daheim stefan thiele
stephanie schiller war damit schließe
jedes redner zu diesem
tagesordnungspunkt und die beiden
anträge der fw fraktion die grundlage
dieser debatte waren die werden jetzt
zur weiteren beratung in die ausschüsse
überwiesen
deswegen haben wir schon gelegenheit